the best way to start writing is to stop
watching videos the second one is maybe
to stop being in videos III yeah but but
I also but that's a joke but as Ford
said there are no jokes it it there is
no substitute for uninterrupted time for
Ford II you know not the killing your
darlings thing of killing your favorite
lines but killing your distractions
first and and then hearing yourself talk
honestly and hearing the way in which or
for me at least
hearing the way that that ideas are
framed in speech give me a sense of how
they might be framed on the page even if
people feel like they're not fluent on
the page or on the screen or on the
screen that we still call a page and
they they probably speak with less
thumbs and ahhs and lose than I do
sometimes and but primarily I think that
the the real question is what are you
writing for and I don't mean knowing
your audience because you can never know
your audience and if you actually want
to write well your goal should be that
your audience isn't conceivable to you
so what I mean is know what you're
trying to find of your self from what
you're writing I think most people are
stuck
because they are either trying to find
another person in what they're writing
or they're not even sure what they are
they're not even sure why they are
hurting themselves so badly you know
writing is a very strange thing because
it is it's not the messy thing that you
give to children in kindergarten
like paints where you can smear it
everywhere or like when they give a
bunch of kindergartners Eila phones and
they drive everyone crazy right because
it requires a little bit more education
right to make the same amount of noise
let's say but writing then becomes the
most basic way besides speech of
communication and people do it very
easily right but then it also becomes
the hardest thing to do
and I actually tend to think about it
like when I go to the zoo which honestly
has probably been twice in the last ten
years
but when you go to the zoo and you watch
animals can you say that on this
you're not thinking and watching of sex
and and you're like oh that's easy
right now there are obviously different
rules animal kingdom or none but it's
thinking like oh if only it were so
simple right and and I think that
getting in touch with some of those
honestly instincts that are animal
inside of us like rage resentment
the strength that comes from fear will
always again make good writing and life
bad if I knew who or what my audience is
was will be then I'm not writing I'm
calculating which is a which I mean in
the way we kind of use the word
calculator but also meaning that kind of
good old American confidence man
huckster sense you know I'm reckoning up
intended effects interpretations I'm
weighing what people are going to read
in certain ways as irony as offensive as
anodyne as print as quote-unquote honest
right and and first of all there's the
there's just the fact that all of these
ideals are normative within generations
you know and and change right so so so
we already know that all of these things
that I'm sort of calculating too are
going to be utterly upended by a younger
generation that's going to consider me
old and passe and worthless
there is though the hope that if you
write with a certain openness to moods
and and states of mind that make you
feel uncomfortable those might be
portents of
future inconceivable moods which then
would really be understood by future and
inconceivable audiences I mean that's
the gamble you take or that's the gamble
I would like to take which is to say to
put myself in a position where I am
unsure as to how something will be
received and maybe unsure as to what
something is but there's something in
the there's some integrity in the
language or there's some integrity in
the playing out of the thought however
disconcerting it might be sometimes to
me or the wildering there there is
something in those states of discomfort
and of discomfort presented in linguists
with linguistic integrity that sort of
makes me believe that someone will read
me and know how to explain that mood to
me right no one no someone will be me
and know how to explain that impulse to
me I think so much of so much of my life
which is inseparable for my writing is
about trying to find explanations for
certain impulses
and that's I think what a what a future
audience might give but of course you
know there's hope just not for us right
you're never gonna be around to have it
all smooth it out for you